Tony's in California hey Tony
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show yes sir
it's a pleasure to talk to you gentlemen
you too sir I'm not gonna help I have
recently come into some money
my great-grandfather has passed away
unfortunately Wow
and he left me 2.8 million dollars and I
am I am sort of you know just just
absolutely floored as to as to what I
should do with it scares you look and
what direction what direction I should
take it you know my my the rest of my
family is relatively wealthy so you know
it how old are you I I don't want I
don't want to hold him under it is only
Tony my my Tony can you ever yes sir how
old are you sir how old are you that how
old are you I'm 30 32 at the end of this
month
have you got a degree in a career what's
your degree in which career yes sir
my my degree is sort of PC upgrade and
repair and my career is is in the same
field okay and so this is a
certification not a four-year
information system to degree right yes
sir
yes sir how long have you been doing
that about about three years okay good
for you three years I think and so when
you got the money
it sounds to me like you were at a
normal reaction which was like 2.8
million dollars
and about 30 seconds later you went oh
crap this is really intimidating yeah
that that's what happens to most people
if they're wise the unwise ones just
keep saying whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo you know
but the the smart let's go oh crap this
is actually a responsibility it's not
just a blessing no your you guys be
right it's a it's a it's a complete yeah
I don't wanna start this up changing
amount of money yeah I don't want to
screw this up what what is it what is it
invested in well I you know so so
currently I'm waiting for the estate to
close and then it will be invested in
stocks and it'll be given over to a
financial advisor gotcha
okay all right here's what I want you to
do you were just hired I want you to
treat it like this
you were just hired as the CEO of a PC
repair company worth 2.8 million dollars
and you know about repairing pcs but you
don't know about running a company that
has 2.8 million dollars the first thing
that you would do if you were the new
CEO of that company is you would begin
to put experts around you not to tell
you what to do but to teach you and
guide you so that after you understood
you could make good decisions to run
this company I have a lot of people in
my company they're smarter than me
but I still make the decisions after
they teach me enough to get me to do
whatever it is we're trying to do around
here okay mm-hmm and the Bible says it
this way and the multitude of counsel
their safety and so have you got a pen
handy something to write on
yes okay I want you away from the people
handling the estate to get a different
financial adviser number one number two
I want you to get in
surance broker in your area number three
I want you to get a CPA in your area to
help with taxes number four I want you
to get an estate planning lawyer an
attorney that does estate planning and
this is your board of directors and
you're gonna pay them some fees for
their time to teach you advise you and
guide you
no single one of them gets to control
you this money is yours it's not theirs
none of them are allowed to be anything
but a teacher if you interview them and
they have the heart of arrogance or the
heart of a salesman not the heart of a
teacher run and get a different one but
if you put five men and women around you
or six men and women and the different
professions around you that are wise and
have the heart of a teacher and are not
trying to scarf your money but are
trying to help you guide you as a
brand-new rich guy mmm you will not
screw up do not put money in things you
do not understand do not let someone
else manage it you learn and you make
the decisions slowly and gradually with
wisdom I think you can do this Tony
apparently your great grandfather
thought you could do this what a vote of
confidence huh that's pretty cool